un vote important pas pour l'espagne et
pour l'euro la catalogne et pas pour les
origines qui sont les miennes même si
évidemment c'est une partie de ce que je
suis de mes racines
mais c'est très important pour pour
l'euro via le brick city ya les
nationalismes vous regardez ce qui se
passe dans notre île c'est très
préoccupant avec ce gouvernement on va
emmerder la droite et l'extrême droite
donc c'est très très important pour
l'avenir de l'espagne bien sûr mais de
l'europe
quel que soit le résultat une sortie par
le haut est possible ben justement je
crois que d'avoir la sortie dépendent
tellement du résultat que bien malin qui
pourrait vous le dire et surtout que
s'il est très forte participation il est
possible qu'une partie de la majorité
silencieuse que m'ont dit c'est à dire
plutôt pas indépendantiste refasse
surface
il ya cette jeune représentant de tx de
da noz qui est là qui a l'air d'être
deux d'être un peu la star du scrutin
enfin tout ça avec point d'interrogation
point d'interrogation mais dans les deux
cas de figure alors si c'est ce sont les
indépendantistes qui l'emportent alors
là c'est situation bloquée et robert
rebelote en quelque sorte que faire mais
si ce sont les anti indépendantistes qui
l'emportent c'est pas gagné pour autant
parce que la société est fracturée
la situation est difficile et je pense
que il va falloir des années pour que la
situation catalan sur aig d'une façon ou
d'une autre que des mauvaises solutions
perspectives n'ont pas forcément je
pense quand même que ou partie des
leaders indépendantistes ont commis des
erreurs lourdes que le pouvoir central
s'est un peu calmée par rapport à ses
premières réactions excessives et que
bon premier cas de figure en effet les
indépendantistes remportent on se parle
plus probable enfin on dit que c'est une
possibilité
d'abord ils sont divisés alors qu'avant
ils étaient unis dans cette division il
ya là une partie qui veut vraiment
appuyer très fort sur le frein et
donc je pense que progressivement les
choses vont se calmer et je suis pas
tellement pessimistes
la situation est moins bien qu'il ya
deux mois un macaron oui parce que
effectivement comme comme vous le
rappeliez un instant la situation
politique est quand même évolué il ya
quand même eu sept sets face à un peu
particulière du leader indépendantiste a
préféré quitter le pays allait
s'installer à bruxelles qui lui a pas
donné une popularité très forte parce
que quand on regarde les derniers
sondages avant le scrutin
effectivement il était en baisse ça n'a
pas servi je pense la cause des
indépendantistes
après après on verra bien le résultat du
scrutin effectivement avec avec un
élément essentiel qui est que l'europe
où tous les états européens ont apporté
un soutien appuyé massif évident aux
dirigeants espagnols
effectivement si on avait un vote qui
allait comme c'est peu probable si on en
croit les premiers sondages vers les
indépendantistes là ça poserait un vrai
problème à la construction européenne
c'est évident matthieu aron le rappeler
car les plus jeunes il a fait une
campagne sur une position assez
victimaire finalement ça lui a pas trop
servi c'est ça qui est un peu moi qui me
frappe c'est que par rapport à il ya
quoi ça fait deux mois ça fait deux mois
maintenant on a quand même le sentiment
si on regarde les sondages pour autant
qu'on puisse croire les sondages mais
pas si on gaza
sinon oui mais bon il faut bien partir
de quelque chose pour discuter sur dix
compte serrières en tout cas si on
regarde les sondages dont malgré tout
même si le niveau absolu et qu'on n'est
pas obligé d'y croire malgré tout les
évolutions et tendances souvent donnent
plus d'indications on a quand même le
sentiment que ça pas tant changé que ça
en deux mois c'est que on aurait pu se
dire le numéro de push demande à
bruxelles grotesque a totalement
discréditée des indépendantistes on
aurait pu se dire que la mise en prison
dès d'un surnombre de leader par madrid
a au contraire remobiliser les
indépendantistes alors peut-être que les
deux se sont annulés mais toujours est
il que finalement si on en croit les
sondages c'est je suis tout sous toute
réserve
on n'a pas l'impression que ça bascule
est violemment d'un côté ou de l'autre
oui là et même si les rapports de force
à l'intérieur ça changeait changé
voilà deux choses on est d'accord 1 la
division entre les indépendantistes déjà
ni deux il avait la conviction ou
l'illusion que une catalogne
indépendante pourrait faire partie de
l'europe là qu'on se sont fait peur ils
avaient confirmé
l'europe a très rarement dit c'est pas
la peine d'espérer et 3 et 3 il ya eu
cet exode de quantité d'entreprises qui
a aussi dans une croûte et ribes
l'altération pas pour autant c'est à
dire que on a l'impression que le niveau
relatif de l'indépendantisme de
lentilles à notre hantise sont les mêmes
mais que le centre de gravité de l'un de
l'autre sont faits mais déplacé que
l'indépendantiste et - indépendantiste
qu'il ne l'était avant différents qui a
fait de choix effectivement partir et
s'exiler lui est un peu en chute et son
numéro 2 lui effectivement quand on
regarde les sondages et est un peu
grosse mais lui a fait le choix d'être
resté dans son pays mariano rajoy a
effectivement mis de l'eau dans son vin
il a enfin la justice continue elle j'ai
vu récemment à rendre des décisions et
puis l'autre leader indépendantiste est
toujours théoriquement prg est toujours
en prison à l'heure où l'on parle donc
je crois que c'est sûr que au lieu dit
amen a parfaitement raison ça beaucoup
nous aider les indépendantistes toutes
ces maladresses de madrid il y en a
peut-être moins aujourd'hui
mais moi ce qui m'étonne un petit peu je
me serais attendu à ce que le camp anti
indépendantistes soit plus fort dans les
sondages alors il sera peut-être ce soir
beaucoup plus fort et qu'on ait un sorte
de briques site à l'envers si vous
voulez puisque le brix et a surpris tout
le monde au dernier moment
donc moi j'avoue que je suis pas spécial
de la catalogne d'une part je trouve que
c'est un petit peu bon ses mystères
m'échappe un peu et je voudrais pas
feindre d'en être l'organisateur
je suis d'accord avec vous en fait pour
tout vous dire moi je pense que les
indépendantistes vont reculer et je ne
crois pas les sondages donc si c'est
confirmé je compte sur vous pour
l'avenir dire que j'ai été très bon et
si c'est infirmer pour l'oublier
donc vous pronostiquez une forte avance
de gildan eaux cde
je représente un taux elle et l'ensemble
des autres dans des moindres proportions
mais que les indépendantistes vont
reculer par rapport au dernier scrutin
je trouve que ce serait dans la logique
et je crois toujours la logique plus que
les sondages notamment pour avoir
longtemps travaillé dans un institut de
sondage
alors on le rappeler c'est vrai que ça a
été une campagne très rude avec une
société qui est très divisée par exemple
le journal le figaro le demain on est un
petit encadré pour dire qu'ils sont tous
ou souvent pioli dick les catalans ou
presque ils appellent ça la révolution
xanax non mais c'était une boutade mais
il ya un côté quand même division à ces
profondeurs
quand même que tout va aller pour le
mieux même si les anti indépendantistes
l'emportent
je pense que sa société est fracturée
fatigué et qui qui va avoir du mal à
recoller les morceaux quand même vous
savez c'est un petit peu là où il ya un
peu un syndrome affaire dreyfus
voilà on en parle on en parlait à table
des familles se déchirent les gens se
parlent plus et des couples divorcent
tout ça ça il peut y avoir un moment où
on a envie peut-être de faire de faire
la paix mais je pense que c'est un
problème plus profond
et puis qui est un problème d'identité
et ses problèmes d'identité taraude
l'europe et on va les voir partout y
compris en france et l'europe
on l'avait aussi est resté
volontairement à l'écart
la position reste nabeul après l'après
scrutin
oui et puis d'ailleurs je crois pas
qu'on va les avoir en france où savez un
catalan ne souhaite jamais un catalan
indépendantiste ne souhaite jamais la
victoire de l'équipe espagnole dans les
mondiaux et c'est son père l'a d'europe1
corse indépendantiste souhaitent la
victoire de l'équipe de france dans les
compétitions de football c'est une
différence considérable ces différences
conciliaire de pose des questions et des
problèmes sont pas évidents évident à la
rentrée avec la victoire des
nationalistes corses
il va y avoir quand même d'aider du
rajustement et non j'appelle ça parce
que même si ce ne sera pas catalan je
vais vous dire non exiger le
rapprochement des prisonniers les
politiques de la libération d'un creuset
politique
le fait que ce gouvernement ne leur a
pas l'idéal mais on ne reprochera pas
grave
autant dire que seuls les les gens qui
sont encore depuis cinq ans grand
d'acheter des terrains et des
de l'immobilier encore c'est un peu plus
délicat ils ont des exigences qui sont
pendant la campagne j'ai dit oui ils
sont devenus sympas ils sont plutôt les
plus ils sont plus du tout les
indépendantistes on se rend compte comme
depuis leur victoire comme lui n'ont pas
renoncé à ce qu'ils sont on va leur
reprocher leur point de vue de l'état
comme ça ils n'y ont pas renoncé et
effectivement les corses et puis là
aussi on a on a deux mouvements un petit
peu différent parce que entre ce que
représente monsieur simeoni est ce que
représente monsieur talamoni ce n'est
pas exactement la même chose en corse
je trouve que dans le numéro de cette
semaine dans l'ope son sort un papier
qui est intéressant c'est le rôle qui a
joué un autre leader nationaliste qui a
été condamné par la justice qui est un
homme qui a un vrai passé de délinquant
un homme qui peut être dangereux qui
s'appelle charles pieri il se trouve que
charles pieri a joué un rôle
considérable dans cette dans cette
élection forçant entre guillemets
monsieur termen talamoni monsieur
simioni elles s'entendent forçant
d'ailleurs surtout monsieur signale
qu'elle n'avait aucune envie
donc il faut la revoir effectivement
dans l'est dans les mois et les années à
venir
quelles conséquences ça va avoir sur la
gestion de sept-îles effectivement le
pouvoir accordé à seynod leemans a
apporté tout cela si nous étions en
belgique on parlait des flamands nous
sommes en france nous interroger sur
leurs pas pour la catalogne on file sur
la corse je veux dire c'est pour ça que
chaque état à cette rixe mais oui mais
c'est vrai qu'une blague c'est pour ça
que chaque état à cette réaction
tellement de solidarité avec aaron hill
s'est pas seulement pour être gentil
avec rajoy
c'est parce que chacun craint que des
effets de contagion chez lui à propos
d'europe et c'est peut-être anecdotique
mais les autrichiens qui propose des
passeports à la minorité germanophone du
haut-adige en italie un signe
d'européennes italienne vous trouviez
pas ça anecdotique du tour il faut
seriez vent debout et vous verrez qu'on
met de l'huile sur le feu pour rien
qu'on a déjà très on a mis longtemps à
calmer
les européens tout à fait que voilà et
c'est un dossier compliqué parce que
donc il fallait l'autonomie 30 dîner
puis ils ont fait un regroupement avec o
t'abuse et après ils ont donné de
l'autonomie à chacune à l'intérieur de
ce regroupement mais la situation
s'était calmée mais évidemment là c'est
quand même remettre 2016 serrée dans ces
deux histoires
ce que je dis c'est que toutes les
situations sont vraiment différentes
vous avez raison puisqu'à catalan est
vraiment paroxystique
mais cette question identitaire balawi
l'autriche nouvel exemple
enfin je veux dire c'est qu'on croyait
que c'était enterré mort et enterré
depuis la défaite de 45 c'est juste dire
encore que l'autriche n'a jamais été
n'est ce pas du côté allemand mais
enterré de 1945 est en fait c'est un
sujet qui traîne depuis la première
guerre mondiale et qui va qui va
ressurgir quand même d'autant que les
italiens en question interrogez annoncé
ces gens ces gens duodénal ige du
trentin je suis pas certain qu'ils
sentent terriblement italien crispations
identitaires qui peuvent prendre deux
formes différentes celle des riches en
ont marre de payer pour les pauvres ce
qui est le cas des catalans ou du nord
de l'italie
ou au contraire de pauvres de ceux qui
se sentent exclus qui en ont marqué dix
ans maintenant on va faire notre notre
notre identité qui sont qui sont les
corses c'est pas le même mais c'est pas
le même ressort mais c'est la même
affirmation de l'identité le sujet en
tout cas passionne beaucoup de réactions
behzad au toit c'est un mal prononcé
mais il faut les laisser les catalans
faire leur vote librement c'est leur
libre arbres y menchu diaz en catalogne
en asthme et de la haine entre des
espagnols n'est pas content du tout et
cela est ignominieux car la catalogne et
l'espagne
et l'espagne est resté et la
souveraineté espagnole s'étend au
territoire catalan merci pour ce débat
deux niveaux au figaro et en navarre les
partis politiques du parti nationaliste
basque qui font partie du gouvernement
navarre vont dans la même direction que
les catalans séparatistes et enfin le
droitise qui nous dit les
indépendantistes se déchirent pourquoi
c'est vrai qu'on l'a abordée dans chaque
camp il ya des divisions qui se sont
fait jour de façon plus profonde de ces
derniers temps nous allons passer à
notre deuxième thème notre deuxième
thème pour qui l'ignoreraient encore
emmanuel macron fête aujourd'hui ses 40
ans un âge qui est indéniablement un
tout pour bousculer le paysage politique
mais une jeunesse qu'il a su
contrebalancée par une présence
présidentialisation de la fonction une
série de récents sondages montrent un
fort regain de popularité
plus d'un français sur deux est
satisfaits de son action selon notre
dernier sondage aux docks sad and
consulting
avec ce tour de force d'avoir réussi à
remonter la pente après un trou d'air
cet été
nous allons parler tout cela mais avant
une petite séquence clin d'oeil
hier soir à 23 heures le téléphone du
président de la république a sonné au
bout du fil
l'animateur cyril hanouna regardez oui
bonsoir président commencera président
ça va très bien
je voulais vous souhaiter bon
anniversaire parce que vous nous aviez
souhaité bon anniversaire sur notre
millième donc oui c'est vrai qu'entre g
vous dire que je viens c'est mal oui
c'est alexis ça se fait ce genre de
beaucoup de chance emmanuel macron date
appelé par cyril hanouna
je sais pas quoi dire ça prouve que vous
aimeriez vraiment une honte à vous
appelle pour vous souhaitez votre ami
heures il a décroché par hasard vous
gardez répond celui décroché
écoutez d'abord je pense pas que c'est
lui qui est monté le coup bon et nous a
évité
line renaud qui sait j'appuie base des
mister president
oui on image à malines j'imagine rap se
valent y'a pas photo quand même oui mais
c'est la dina c'est lui qui la propriété
et
voilà ce que je vous dise de plus si bon
sinon ce qui est intéressant dans toute
cette histoire est particulièrement dans
les sondages que vous évoquez c'est que
vous avez d'une part un certain nombre
d'items comme on dit sur laquelle on
pourrait penser que les réponses ne sont
pas bonnes pour macron président des
riches ou dans une autre enquête manque
d'humilité un monarque républicain et en
même temps que si je puis dire soigner
trois fois remontée de popularité c'est
ça qui est passionnant c'est que malgré
les défauts qu'il lui attribue
majoritairement et qui continue à lui
attribuer les français sont devenus plus
favorables à lui qu avant moi je trouve
c'est cette contradiction qui est
intéressante oui alors dans cette
remontée de popularité il faudrait
analyser pourquoi du comment
son attitude lors des deux cérémonie des
obsèques de jean d'ormesson et de johnny
hallyday sur des registres un peu
différent je crois a été apprécié et
salué à peu près par tout le monde et
après c'est quand même un génial
président du en même temps parce que il
a réussi quelques pas à se
représidentialiser au début de son
mandat par rapport aux autres présidents
précédents
donc il a il a incarné totalement cette
fonction il le fait dans une en majesté
dans le faste et généralement ça se
traduit par des corps et en même temps
il répond au téléphone à cyril hanouna
dans une émission extrêmement populaire
un million un million et demi de
spectateurs
beaucoup de gens très jeunes qui
regardent donc il y joue sur ces
différents registres avec il faut lui
reconnaître une certaine maestria
voilà alors il y en a un qui fait du
tout convaincu par cette communication
c'est nicolas bay le vice président du
front national
il était ce matin sur france info on
écoute on en reparle le sentiment qu'on
a surtout c'est que manuel macron à a
baissé très rapidement en une façon
spectaculaire plus rapide d'ailleurs que
ses prédécesseurs
donc c'est peut-être aussi ce qui
explique aujourd'hui parce qu'elle il a
quelques habiletés de communication il
parvient à remonter mais voilà
globalement il est question oui je crois
principalement je crois pas que ce soit
ses orientations politiques qui suscite
la moindre satisfaction pour les
français avaient trop de champagne parce
que c'est son anniversaire aussi l'aider
le même jury saignements mais bien dû
prendre
du champagne par anticipation la théorie
de guerre monde parce qu'il avait baissé
alors là c'est la même lancée que le
début de sa phrase est vrai c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que que l'on m'accorde
pas partie de haut et c'est vrai qu'il a
beaucoup baissé
oui mais c'est d'autant plus incroyable
parce que ça c'est dur ça s'il ya un
côté ça c'est pas un côté c'est du
jamais vu à ce moment-là du d'un
quinquennat hors cohabitation on a déjà
vu des présents qui remontait mais parce
qu'il avait une rupture politique
la cohabitation s'installe mais sinon ça
fait que baisser et là ils remontent
très fortement vous êtes de bonne foi
mais non merci à la différence de
nicolas bay s'est très bien vous mais
non mais quand on regarde ailleurs les
quant aux protections sur l'action du
président c'est parce qu'au delà de la
communication évidemment mais n'empêche
que sur un peu plein d'items que ce soit
la sécurité l'immigration choses n'en
parlons pas et même l'économie
finalement alors il reste encore un poil
minoritaires normalement le président
genoux l'économie mais la vente mais il
apprend qu il a gagné sept ou huit
points à chaque fois surtout parce qu'il
est notable freenautes et c'est le hir
gagnent des points à gauche sans en
perdre la droite et a ce côté c'est pas
que de jolis en tout cas on peut danser
tant que je me relie la popularité après
effectivement j'ai regardé j'ai vu comme
vous qui effectivement à gauche même
s'il était toujours majoritaires à
droite à gauche effectivement il
remontait il ya quand même un dossier
sur lequel ils foutent le fasse à mon
avis un petit peu attention mais quand
on voit la capacité de réaction de
seconde norme on s'aperçoit qu'ils en
aient ils ont donc j'ai déjà pris
conscience c'est celui des réfugiés
c'est celui des réfugiés puisque là
visiblement
il se retrouve face à passer des paroles
de gens qui ne sont pas entre guillemets
des excités ou des radicaliser de toute
une série d'associations qui sont des
associations raisonnable qui gère ses
centres que mettre par exemple monsieur
gallois a une parole forte qui était
président de l'association ela
visiblement ce qui a déclaré l'élu le
projet de loi qui est à l'étude ou la
proposition de loi qui est à l'étude
inquiète beaucoup d'associations mais je
crois savoir que il était il ya une
heure dans le bureau du premier ministre
bas et que donc il est en train de se
négocier probablement quelque chose pour
leur donner ainsi quoi c'est
effectivement si c'est parce que tout ce
qui a été dit est absolument vrai moi je
crois quand même que la communication en
général j'en ai du mal mais franchement
faire d'ormesson et johnny hallyday
c'est ça qui est en même temps très fort
c'est à dire que rihanna corps est très
bien fait l'un ou l'autre faire les deux
très bien ça le chapeau c'est plus que
la communication là on est vraiment mais
je crois qu'il faut aussi quand même
voir que et emmanuel macron qu'on dit
toujours disciple de rigueur mais qui
est d'abord n'oublions n'oublions jamais
indécis de machiavel c'est que les
choses peuvent se retourner très vite
parce que là j'avais vu ça aussi à
l'époque de la macro latry juste après
son élection et tout le monde disait
c'est vite retombée donc il faut faire
un petit peu attention à ça je suis sûr
que lui en est conscient je suis moins
sûr que son entourage en soit conscient
mais il faut quand même toujours pensé à
dame fortune qui peut lui apporter un
attentat ailleurs une crise économique
etc et d'autre part il ya des faiblesses
qui peuvent construire un con tre récit
là le récit positive se met en place
mais il peut se construire un contre
récit sur la laïcité l'immigration la
certain nombre de mesures fiscales par
exemple le fait que les impôts vont
augmenter ça commence à être un thème
qui va moins plaire à droite
à mon avis il peut se faire se mettre en
place cinq autres récits évidemment à
condition que l'opposition sous la bonne
oui c'est à dire qu'il ya certaines
choses qui sont aujourd'hui pour quand
ça va bien ensemble de choses qui sont
face entre deux choses qui sont portées
à votre actif quand ça va bien
notamment le côté monarchie parce que
certains d'entre vous serez peuvent se
retourner contre vous quand ça va mal
bon par exemple sarkozy et c'est vrai
que les français sont à la fois
monarchique même coupé la tête du roi
est donc aujourd'hui ils sont contents
et cette verticalité 4 établi ma console
mais demain ils peuvent lui en vouloir
et lui en continuant vouloir d'autant
plus violemment que ils l'ont ils n'ont
et mais j'ajouterai que et ça je crois
que est là pour le coup autour de mâcon
et lyon sont confiants c'est que cet
effet de souffle et fait d'élection
l'effet des demies malgré de plus on
avance dans les difficultés plus ça
s'estompe pia salanque de réformes qui
voit difficile à mettre en oeuvre et et
que les résultats pour le coup sont pas
là jamais là tout de suite
donc si on ajoute tout ça c'est vrai que
des difficultés pour arriver pour autant
moi je crois pas du tout qu'il aurait
raison de recommencer a reculé notamment
sur les migrations
bien sûr il a contrôlé plein
d'associations qu'un drôle et d'opinion
et compris jacques toubon beau c'est une
catastrophe
mais il n'a pas les ptom populaires
contre eux mais la tension mais c'est
vrai que c'est embêtant d'avoir que
jacques toubon de ressaut atterrissent
lectorat populaire
suivront là dessus parce que la coupure
des problèmes de maquereaux cette coupe
électorat populaire d'un côté président
des riches et bien sûr ces questions
d'immigration bien sûr les associations
etc
mais le le dira lectorat populaire les
réfugiés politiques on les accepte les
réfugiés économiques parce qu'a donc pas
d'emploi pas de conditions de logement
doivent rentrer chez eux
lecteur polaris hui signe des donneurs
d'accord la majorité de la population
vient de faire cette enquête à la
fondapol élire ses frais dans toute
l'europe
la majorité de la population est contre
l'accueil des réfugiés tout en disant
moralement il faut le faire mais surtout
à condition de ne pas le faire et les
classes populaires en france et 62% dans
les classes populaires qui s'opposent à
l'accueil des réfugiés migrants réfugiés
migrants pas réfugié politique si on
pose la question comme ça si on parle
des migrants et de réfugiés politiques
on n'a pas du tout les mêmes réponses
donc là il ya une donnée qui fait que
mêmes acron qui encore une fois est
machiavélien ce qu'on peut dire
machiavélique peut tout à fait être
amené à considérer que des mesures
fortes en matière d'immigration pourrait
au contraire le rapprocher des classes
populaires et pas seulement comme on
croit la droite de la droite
et jusqu'où on peut aller
a sion des associations plutôt humaniste
voire droits de l'hommistes héros
certains oui mais il faut pas réduire ce
à quelques petits groupes
droit-de-l'hommiste ce sens ce sont 4
130 associations qui expriment le même
point de vue qui représente parmi tous
ceux qui travaillent avec elle 11
millions de personnes donc c'est un
phénomène comme il ya parfois une sorte
de dichotomie chez un certain nombre de
français
la même manière que personnellement ils
sont heureux et puis qui disent que ça
va mal et bien personnellement ici ou là
il est des migrants et en même temps me
disait il faut arrêter l'immigration
donc il y avait beaucoup de gens quelque
chose de contradictoire et puis ni macro
ni personne d'autre mais même macron
qu'il prétend aimer tenir un discours de
vérité
ils n'osent pas tellement s'avancer là
dessus la vérité c'est que tout le monde
nous répète depuis des années que l'on
doit accueillir et bien accueillir les
demandeurs d'asile et qu'on doit rejeter
les réfugiés économiques mais c'est une
distinction qui ne tiendra pas c'est une
élection qui ne tiendra pas regarder
imaginez juste imaginé pour qu'on
comprenne ce que je veux dire imaginez
que bangladesh soient submergés sous les
eaux et qui est 50 millions 20 millions
de bengalis dans l'air et c'est bon et
on dira ah bah non cédées sont pas des
persécutés de liberté il reflète pas le
droit résident donc on n'en prend pas
non mais ce sera parce que c'est un cas
de soudaines et des erythréens
ces gens là sortie de réfugiés
économiques ou politiques il serait pas
passer ses nuits matière sont complets
que
un réfugié qui au départ pourrait être
considérée comme un régime économique
qui a quitté son pays d' à ce qu
effectivement il voulait aller vivre un
avenir meilleur ailleurs et qui est
passé pendant quelques mois en libye qui
a été emprisonné qui a été réduit en
esclavage
une façon déguisée ou direct qui ensuite
passe en italie où il s'est là aussi vu
des fois vu infligé un traitement qui
n'était pas des plus agréables qui finit
par arriver en france au bout d'un an et
demi bien difficile de dire si on va lui
accorder le statut de réfugié pour des
raisons humanitaires
ce qui au regard de son parcours et de
son voyage pour être parfaitement
compris tout ça pour dire que je croyais
pas d'accord avec vous je pense que on
évolue assez soit 7 sur 7
ce qui a été une polémique la
distinction entre réfugiés économiques
et réfugiés politiques les gens ont fini
par comprendre que c'était pas aussi
clair que ça et je pense que je pense
que les politiques
je crois que de politique comprend que
effectivement derrière ces associations
il ya des centaines de milliers de gens
où des dizaines de milliers de gens qui
s'activent il ya des millions de gens
est effectivement comme vous le disiez
quand on pose la question aux gens de
savoir si il accepte qu'on puisse
accueillir dignement un réfugié
politique je pense que les gens disent
assez majoritairement oui si on dit un
migrant économies qu'ils vont dire
majoritairement non mais chez séché
chacun d'entre nous que se pose ce
dilemme et il y a plein de gens de bonne
volonté qui n'en est pas une réponse
aussi automatique que ce qu'on imagine
donc les sondages disent quelque chose
je les vois même pas d'accord maintenant
moi je suis pas d'accord je pense qu'au
contraire jean noël bien décoré pas
d'accord évidemment une vérité là dedans
mais pendant des années la doctrine
c'était quoi c'était celle de rocard qui
était la france va accueillir toute la
misère du monde mais ne reprendra pas ce
qui est nouveau dans le discours de pied
70 en tout cas dans la bouche d'un
président à public c'est de dire la
france doit prendre aucune part de la
misère du monde mais doit prendre une
part de la misère l'oppression de
l'oppression exactement
donc on fait l'addition alors après dire
que concrètement c'est difficile bien
sûr tout est difficile mais c'est pas
une raison parce que c'est difficile
qu'il faut pas du tout le temps t il ya
malgré tout beaucoup et on le voit de
populations qui viennent d'afrique qui
ne sont pas du tout rien qui sont pas du
tout aux prix mais oui quand emmanuel
macron dit à une marocaine les yeux dans
les yeux
madame jeune femme madame il faut
rentrer dans votre pays parce que vous
n'êtes pas opprimées dans votre pays
la cdc s'est passé 50 messages quand
même bien sûr mais si moi je vous dis qu
un jeune erythréen qui est condamné à
faire le service militaire avis notre
visage répondu les difficultés pour son
action en faveur de la liberté
il aura toujours des qualités mais moi
je vous dis que l'opinion multiplient
non mais il ya toujours des trois jours
est capable de définir des nouvelles
tu es gorille qui distingue en effet des
gens qui n'ont pas de problèmes dans
leur pays qu'ils ne viennent que parce
qu'ils ont un cousin ou ça va mieux à
londres et que ça les temps le gens qui
sont donc des situations de biens non
pas à l'état de victoria la leur liberté
mais d'absolu précarité d'inhumanité sur
l'a6 déjà macron le faisais ça aurait un
effet considérable sur le nombre de gens
qui rentrent lui dont l'immense majorité
vient pour des raisons économiques on
l'a vu des réfugiés des réfugiés de
guerre il y en a très peu dans nos
villes c'est pas en france qui sont nous
ce sont des réfugiés économiques
et c'est je crois qu en tout cas je dis
pas que c'est facile à faire mais je dis
que l'opinion une dose de droite comme
de gauche notamment la catégorie
populaire est de plus en plus
demandeuses de ça et de plus en plus
alors on peut le regretter d'un point de
vue moral mais intolérante et de plus on
rejette d'un point de vue moral on doit
expliquer et bien progressé et bouger et
aux gens comme vous on considère que
c'est un bon thème politique de bien de
toi mais c'est notamment qui font la
musique c'est un thème de gauche
peut-être une trêve à vous c'est pas mal
c'est de macao qu'aider on va revenir
l'empêché pas être content bien sûr
question du maroc soit exactement celle
à laquelle doit faire face parce que
quand on reprend la phrase de michel
rocard effectivement la france ne peut
pas accueillir toute la misère du monde
mais doit prendre sa juste part
tout le problème qui a été posée ces
dernières années ces trois ou quatre
dernières années c'est que la france n'a
pas pris sa juste part alors la france à
bas prix s'est pas déplacé là très
discret non c'est parce que je dis moi
c'est ce qui est la vérité d'autres
excusez moi la france selon un sondage
som la france a pas pris sa juste part
pourquoi pour deux raisons d'abord parce
qu'il ya eu un mouvement d'émigration
massive qui sait qui c'est qui s'est
déclenché à partir de 2013 2014
venant de syrie et d'irak effectivement
et c'est vrai les responsables
politiques de l'époque socialiste disait
ben nous on voudrait bien cueillir des
gens mais il ne se dirige pas
directement vers notre pays et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont été en masse en
allemagne et aussi par exemple comme des
pays comme la suède est encore plus joli
vent est aujourd'hui encore plus
solidement derrière ça il ya eu d'autres
d'autres pays effectivement où on a vu
des
des mouvements migratoires que ça vienne
que les gens arrivent d'erythrée
d'afghanistan ou du soudan ce qui se
passe là ce qui ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe là d aller dans les centres
d'art et à l'est dans les centres d
après débat les albanais c'est publié on
a pu découvrir quand même vous
reconnaissez infusion d'afghans à des
reclassements d'africains vous les
reconnaissez pardon de vous distinguer
en afrique 1 2 mais les statistiques par
nationalité on les a dans la rue c'est
comme dans la rue qui vous verrez les
statistiques sont très claires la
majorité des l'immigration demandes
d'immigration clandestine en france
vient d'afrique et moi la majorité de
l'immigration vous avez raison
effectivement mais pas la majorité de
l'émigration de gens qui sont réfugiées
vos compétences élargies aux côtés de
ted voilà les vrais réfugiés devraient
opprimés parce qu'on accueille des
réfugiés économiques
mais maintenant qu'il faut pas
accueillir les réfugiés économiques
voilà c'est à dire internet qui me voit
qu'il va devoir être pas la canadienne
quoi qu'on dise il faut bien voir que
sur la question des de l'immigration
c'est pas une question pour les
prochains mois c'est une question qui va
faire que gros croître et grandir et
prendre de l'ampleur non mais il faut
quand même voir les choses telles
qu'elles sont et l'opinion publique ne
va pas se retourner même si à juste
titre on milite pour donner sens ou dans
l'autre c'est moi je suis tout à fait de
votre avis très vite une situation très
singulière en 2013 2014 on a eu un
mouvement migratoire massif qui est
passé d'abord par la grèce par l'italie
2 1 millions et demi de millions de
personnes
voilà c'est ça à quoi on est confronté
aujourd'hui ce mouvement là et vous
regardez tous les chiffres
il sait aujourd'hui si ce n'est arrêté
paris parce qu'effectivement la porte
aux grecs ccfa s'est refermé on a
refermé la porte italienne donc la
question à laquelle on est confronté
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si ces gens
qui sont passés effectivement on arrive
dans un certain nombre de pays européens
à les accueillir plus ou moins dignement
l'allemagne a rempli son rôle la suède
art en prison d'autres pays européens
ont accueilli y ait des gens les
et ces immigrés qui se promènent en
europe et qui passent d'un pays à
l'autre maintenant arrive un peu plus
nombreux en france c'est ça qui se passe
là et c'est de savoir si d'autres qui
arrivent d'ailleurs que minutes on a
fermé les notes puis foulée casey bell
s'est passé ben non ça côté les jours
oui mais regardez les chiffres c'est pas
exactement la même arrivée qu'il ya trop
capricieux vous resterez comment qui
vous aussi vous avez apprécié mais on se
mêle alors emmanuel macron doit-il être
plus laïque
en tout cas il reçoit aujourd'hui les
représentants des cultes
c'est un autre dossier sensible est
assez proche finalement de celui
d'émigrants le celui de la question de
la laïcité de la lutte contre le
communautarisme avant une intervention
du président de la république qui est
attendu en janvier
un président qui jusqu'à présent s'est
gardé de propos trop tranché sur la
question au point que ses adversaires
lui reproche d'être flou
alors donc je le disais les
représentants des cultes était cet après
midi à l'elysée une question un peu
piège vous connaissez le nom du
représentant des musulmans
il y en a eu plusieurs puisqu'il a même
reçu ce matin le représentant donc assez
original lui en tout cas quelqu'un son
équipe a été reçue à l'elysée sur
l'entente des musulmans athées ou
l'ancien musulmans mais que son opinion
est floue à la jeunesse jusqu'à présent
je suis passé tout à fait d'accord avec
vous il a développé un point de vue sur
la laïcité pendant la campagne qui est
très clair qui es-tu ce qu'on appelle la
laïcité très ouvert ses adversaires lui
reproche d'être flou non lui reproche
d'être pas d'être flou d'être d'une
certaine conception très commis dit
lui-même très libérale très positive
c'est à dire il considère en fait que la
laïcité c'est la liberté religieuse
c'est ce qu'il a dit dans la campagne et
donc ça s'est très mal pris évidemment
par un certain nombre de gens à droite
mais aussi par le camp laïc
on va dire purs et durs de la gauche
donc là dessus il ne sait pas ils
devaient se prononcer il avait été
question qu'il se prononça en décembre
lors de l'année et sa constance et
beaucoup à faire en ce sens qu'ils
évitent le sujet on dit qu'il peut le
dire en janvier on a absolument aucune
preuve et je pense que sur ces questions
total a aussi les événements et là
encore que ça plaise ou simple est ce
pas il devra prendre une position
en tout cas je sais pas en tout cas une
position qui qui ne lui aliène pas
l'opinion parce que c'est quand même
préoccupation pour lui on vit dans un
drôle de pays dans lequel d'une part je
parle là de l'ensemble des commentateurs
je me mets dans de l'eau évidemment
d'une part critique plutôt rail parfois
pourfendre le fait que le président de
la république s'occupe de tout et
d'autre part quand il ne s'occupe pas de
quelque chose on le somme de le faire et
l'on dit mais comment vous ne vous êtes
pas intervenu là dessus vous n'avez rien
dit sur le drame les femmes
sur la polémique charlie vous n'avez
rien dit sur les agressions sexuelles
vous ne vous n'avez rien dit sur la
laïcité on déroule comme ça l'iran
semble d'accord mais où est le problème
où est le problème mais comment est-ce
qu'on est toujours aujourd'hui confronté
en france un grave problème la laïcité
qu'il faut absolument donner du coeur à
écouter la jetée est vraiment allé dans
une école boulle verrez que tout de
suite non mais selon le ministre de
l'éducation nationale ne cesse de dire
ce qu'il faut lui convient de faire être
pas faire et le chariot de mes gamins
fort bien charlie et mediapart il a bien
fait pas intervenir dans ce débat parce
que vraiment fait ce qu'ils avaient à
s'en mêler
oui puis surtout c'était des querelles
intra gauche d'une extrême violence dans
lesquelles il n'avait pas à prendre le
président ne parle pas de la laïcité je
peux pas cautionner ça se passe tu peux
pas parler tout l'argument d'un parent
tout mais l'apparence et qu'il
intervienne satirique au label
ils interviennent parce que vous ne
mettrez pas en deux mois en essayant de
me faire des comparaisons peu flatteuses
et c'est un euphémisme on égare non au
contraire je voulais faire
alors maintenant c'est un compliment
vous prenez de travers alexis écouter
non ça va non mais que des questions de
laïcité se pose
je crois que c'est de l'ordre de
l'évidence quand on regarde ce qui se
passe à l'école par exemple monsieur
blanc caire a relancé renforcer les
unités laïcité donc il a estimé lui
qu'il y avait un besoin à l'école parce
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
professeurs se retrouvent à enseigner
des choses qui sont remises en cause par
des élèves donc on met en place des
unités laïcité que la laïcité puisse
poser question dans l'entreprise oui on
le sait les enquêtes le montrent là
aussi même si ce phénomène n'est pas en
hausse par rapport à ces dernières
années on s'aperçoit qu'il est à peu
près stable quand on interroge les
cadres dirigeants mais que 60 % des
cadres répondra oui j'ai été confronté à
des situations où effectivement la
question de la laïcité s'est posée de
même à l'hôpital où on sait qu'il est
impossible donc de manière pragmatique à
l'hôpital à l'école 2007 les gens
essayent de
de faire en sorte de respecter la
laïcité et de ne pas sortir des grands
principes
après est ce que le président doit ou
pas s'emparer de cette question sur la
polémique entre effectivement mediapart
est charlie je pense qu'on était dans
une police politique passionné avec
d'autres à gauche très fortement on
connaît les tenants et les aboutissants
chacun a ses opinions là dessus
est-ce que c'était au président
d'intervenir je ne le crois pas
fondamentalement fin à ce que plus
globalement il le fasse bon de charlie
hebdo qui donne une interview au point
cette semaine qui dit emmanuel macron
lui qui se veut le leader d'europe il
faudrait qu'il soit aussi le leader de
europe sur cette question cruciale
c'est son rendez vous avec l'histoire
car il ya un vrai enjeu les choses ne se
résume pas l'économie
peut-être est-il en train de louper le
coche c'est l'accusation c'est la
position de ris on connaît ses positions
on connaît les positions tout à fait
estimable d'ailleurs au demeurant de
l'équipe de charlie sur ces questions
voilà fréquemment après je crois que le
président maquereau ou multi mais que ce
n'était pas de son devoir d'intervenir à
ce moment là dans ce débat mais je suis
d'accord avec les battre à mort un
moment un moment très large qui pose une
question aux délits que ce soit la
laïcité que ce soit l'identité qu'il
fasse une grande intervention il ya un
moment où on est sensation de voix on
passe ou un piège pour politique donc
c'est compliqué parce qu'effectivement
il est coincé il ya là une aile gauche
laïcarde 14 mai d'ailleurs qui s'exprime
je ne sais pas si on peut la qualifier
d'ultra leica mais marlène schiappa
secrétaire d'état vient sortir un livre
qui apparemment va être fait pour
l'exposition traits philosophie nous
autres on discutera est-ce que c'est
d'aller cité un peu ouvert un peu
entrouverte un peu fermé un peu trop
lake mais tous avec le rappelle nous à
nous nos commandes à faire mais c'est
pas le boulot du président de fixer les
concepts le bund présence et d'agir
et là je rejoue un mathieu et un certain
nombre de problèmes dans ce pays
donc s'il parle c'est pour apporter des
solutions à ces problèmes dire on va
prendre de nouvelles lois nouveau
règlement ou bien faire appliquer les
lois existant les règlements existants
ça serait déjà beaucoup
c'est ça le boulot des gouvernants les
grandes discussions philosophiques très
sanctionné principe il est enfin il va
quoi dire
sansal évidemment principe de séparation
avec eux leur religion alors que la
chatte un peu croire mais parfois vous
voulez comme nous tous les possibles
il fera le grand discours la question
c'est ce qui se passe dans les quartiers
la question c'est ca tant de populations
qui ne respectent pas la laïcité ou qui
ne respectent pas les femmes où vous les
blairistes voile avant ça il ya des
vraies questions ou à l'école on n'a pas
droit à ceci on parlera de cela ou les
gueux les garçons les filles ce
traitement et qu'est-ce qui peut y faire
il peut et au plus c'est assez ministre
s'occupe lancker de trucs à faire ceux
qui parce que parce que au-delà de parce
que quand on parle de la loi de 1905
au-delà de ces deux premiers articles
qui fixe effectivement les grands
principes de la séparation de l'église
et des tailles de la neutralité de
l'état des théories des églises et de
l'état
encore que la loi de 1905 concernaient
essentiellement une église mais
effectivement des églises et de l'état
quand on regarde le raid de la loi de
1905 ses vingt-cinq ou trente articles
qui suivent elle ne parle que d'eux d'un
problème qui est que à partir du moment
où on va séparer
comment on va faire plaisir à son mari
le duc qui vont appartenir effectivement
les lieux de culte et comment on va rien
nous les prêtres
c'est ça c'est ça la voix des avions
soit sur les ailes notre vie si du
religieux
oui elle ne dit rien elle me dit elle ne
dit rien des questions qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui quotidien mais nancy mais
n'ont été que 28 sur les manifestations
et religieux dans l'espace public on
vient
mais ce que je ne dis pas rien ça
changera pas leur est peu de chose
non mais en tout cas c'est un peu comme
sur l'immigration quant aux renards l'an
dernier on n'est pas d'accord mais quand
on regarde c'est une préoccupation
populaire profonde cette question là et
c'est pas du tout un non sujet et c'est
un sujet extrêmement basses quand vous
tapez dans les saignements conseils
d'enseignement
c'est plus de la majorité des
professeurs qui se sont heurtés à ce
problème
c'est plus de la majorité c'est pas que
je dis pas du tout donc attention je ne
dis pas qu'elle est la réponse qu'il
doit faire comprenez moi bien je que je
disais qu'il ya une attente c'est là que
ne soit pas d'accord avec olivier
duhamel
moi j'aime
at forte pour un éclaircissement du
président a abandonné ou un autre pour
qu'ils fixent un petit peu les principes
moi je dirais qu'une attente d'action
lac jusque de d'harcourt disque où on
peut tous le faire d'accord allez vous
rejoignez le la position au mori qui
s'expriment sur figaro.fr ce sont ceux
qui parlent le plus qui la pratiquent le
moindre set et la laïcité c'est un
concept tout à chacun mais le met à
toutes les sauces
et si possible la sienne on va parler
d'un thème un petit peu c'est celui de
la sanction qui a été confirmé pour
françois ruffin député la france
insoumise avoir porté un maillot de foot
dans l'assemblée lui voir rappel à
l'ordre est un quart de c1 diminué
mensuels soit 1300 78 euros au premier
abord ce n'est qu'une péripétie d'un
trublion amateurs de coups d'éclat mais
les défenseurs de rufin juge qu'il porte
un vrai combat la dénonciation des
transferts faramineux dans le foot
alors qui a tord car nous allons en
parler mais d'abord on écoute françois
de rugy françois de rugy président de
l'assemblée nationale qui exprime lui sa
position est justifiée la sanction notre
assemblée et le lieu du débat pluraliste
en revanche ce n'est pas un théâtre où
on vient avec des costumes et
déguisements
un jour un maillot de foot peut-être
demain quelque chose inspiré d'un
uniforme d'un
d'une tenue religieuse on parlera un
jour de la lutte contre les insectes ici
tueur d'abeilles on viendra avec une
tenue d'apiculteur ça ce n'est pas
possible
la raison pour cela dont je ne suis pas
d'accord
souvenez vous nous vous avez fait
débattre sur la levée d'immunité
parlementaire de marine le pen et
j'avais dit que j'étais très hostile
qu'on ait voté cette levée d'immunité
parce qu'il fallait protéger les ex
toutes les expressions de conviction
opinions et autres dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons il ya plusieurs
façons d'exprimer ses opinions et très
clairement l'image en est une et même
parfois l'image est une façon plus
efficace qu d'autres d'exprimer son
opinion
donc le fait qu'on puisse dire
absolument n'importe quoi la tribune de
l'assemblée mais qu'on n'ait pas le
droit d'exprimer une protestation ou une
opinion pas en l'espèce un maillot de
foot un maillot de foot et demain je ne
sais quoi
non moi je trouve ça plutôt joyeux gay
nous dire que l'assemblée par un théâtre
on rigole attendait ça tape mais
s'attarde donc voilà donc quand on met
un peu de lumière dans lequel je suis
pour tout rhétoriquement parce que
l'argumentation est écrit une lettre à
rigide lagarde et de françois là et il a
écrit une lettre qui est très très
intéressante très très habile très bien
tourné et a fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est dans les camps se battent sur la
forme et le fond c'est-à-dire tout le
monde dit que la question de fond est
intéressante et importante
et d'autres disent oui mais voilà il ya
des respects déconner souvenir ça
m'intéresse endroit vraiment comme
observateur des codes
sinon j'ai pas de religion mais aussi la
défense britannique s'est rendu très
grand service à rufin ont été très déçus
que rudy ne le prive pas d'un bien sûr
il fait ça pour ça il fait de
l'agit-prop il fait il fait un scandale
exprès pour qu'on le lui dise ces
branchements réaction va bien sûr et
bien c'est évident mais je veux d'abord
dire que l'assemblée on peut tout dire
c'est pas vrai moi je me souviens de
l'époque très lointaine il est vrai ou
madelin et je crois séguin et d'aubert
cet effet privé interdirait privé de la
moitié de leur immunité
parce qu'il avait rappelé un fait
historique absolument certain qu'ils
étaient le passé de frau de françois
mitterrand sous l'occupation notamment
sa francisque c'était quand même d'un
point de vue c'était une sanction plus
grave pour des faits qui pour le coup
était pas de guitare ici mais à la
veille du chef d'état vous avez une
félicite pour un culturiste assez rare
chez l'ordalie voilà quelques années
vous n'avez pas de sens quand même temps
mais délègue donc vous avez trouvé le
petit truc qui tablent d'ailleurs les
autres addictions bah ouais mais
relativement peu dire ce qu'on veut en
tout cas se déguiser en clown enfin il
vient montfort et et s'il fallait pas
que messi rufin il veut défendre un club
de foot il est obligé de se déguiser en
footballeur simplement il fait de
l'agit-prop parce que c'est un agitateur
malin et pour avoir une sanction il a sa
sanction on en parle tout le monde est
content 12 ans d'égal moi même s'il
avait dénoncé lé transfert excessif est
tout ouïe ben oui mais si on transmet
alors ça veut dire que l'hommage à coups
comme celui qui voudra dénonce et qui
voudra dénoncer les producteurs de lait
se déguisera en vaches normandes quoi
pas eh ben oui bah ça deviendra
grotesque alors si vous voulez
ridiculiser la saulaie palud de la borda
parlement alors c'est vrai que c'était
le parlement européen qui bon mais enfin
quand même un parlementaire comme ou de
rigueur
mais de savoir si des soutiens mes
joueurs étaient des femmes dans l'europe
et ça l'est toujours très non si vous
voulez que que j'étais fan pis elle
était agent menacé de poursuites rejoint
merouane cette affaire entre guillemets
russe à l'assemblée sa bosse en bosse
pas ça passionne pas tant les
internautes que ça et je dirais même
plus autre chose c'est que sur twitter
ça ne passionne que les députés de la
france a soumises alors il ya le député
adrien cap 9 qui nous dit comme mes
collègues de la france soumise je ne
participe pas au pot de l'assemblée
nationale ce soir donc c'était hier soir
aucune envie d'aller trinquer avec
françois de rugy que se comportent en
tirano je digère mal la sanction les
petits fours ne passerait pas clémentine
autain qui dit la même chose hier
sanctions contre françois ruffin
l'autoritarisme de rigide nous a coupé
tout appétit pour ces petits fours ce
soir pas de cocktails pour les débuter
de la france insoumise eric coquerel qui
écrit à l'unanimité moins notre voie le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale a
confirmé la sanction réflexe de peur du
vieux monde de la vème république la
république en marche compris qui sait
que le vrai pouvoir est ailleurs et y
consent on a le rédacteur en chef
politique de paris match qui écrit la
forme est regrettable mais rufin a
raison sur le fond dans sa défense du
foot amateur et du côté nos internautes
c'est plus ou moins les mêmes avis on
nage à val de la javel ce n'était
peut-être pas très intelligent de
s'habiller comme ça l'assemblée
nationale mais je demande comment on
peut sanctionner quelqu'un là dessus
gênant de voir l'apparence jugé par des
députés rase qui nous dit c'est clair
que les institutions de la république
sont mises en danger par une telle tenue
petite ironie
ne peut-on pas le déchoir de ses
fonctions et enfin gourou 51 il ya
pourtant un proverbe qui dit l'habit ne
fait pas lemoine comme la veste ou le
costume ne font pas de débuter
qu'est ce qui se passe et on vient ici
au figaro avec un maillot de foot on se
prend une avance non c'est super on est
vous porterez à tout casser la semaine
prochaine alexis parce que point de vue
se met un petit peu en vacances mais
merci en tout cas avoue catherine vie
merci à toute l'équipe de point de vue
merci à vincent euros qui met toute son
énergie à préparer cette émission avec
moi merci à charlotte darche qui a
toujours l'oeil et le bon pour la mettre
en images merci aussi elle aime marie
laëtitia bonavita lorraine trillard et
victor lefebvre qui unissent nos invités
autour de ce plateau toujours avec bonne
humeur et courtoisie et un grand merci
enfin à la régie à valérie ans l'inde
d'un jardin bazin jean-charles cousin
qui actionne des manettes et pousse des
boutons et ça marche
bon noël à tous bonne fin d'année ne
manquait pas un dernier point de vue
demain on se retrouve en janvier
[Musique]